we are delighted to have in our studio
Daniel Yergin
the world's leading expert on energy he
is the founder and chairman of Cambridge
Energy Research Associates and they
Pulitzer Prize winning author of books
the latest one is the price and the
price has just been reissued with a new
epilogue written by Daniel Yergin
looking at globalization of demand so
welcome to you thank you since the 2008
crisis the worldwide warrior or shooting
price of oil and wall running out of oil
has subsided but now recently the price
of oil is again going up like today I
think it was $85 and it could be 90 how
do you see the prospect of the price of
oil and how does it relate to the
economic recovery that we so badly
needed the whenever you get into a
market where the price is going up fast
and it seems to be a tight market you
get the worries about running out of oil
peak oil and it piqued those concerns
with a peak in price of one hundred and
forty seven dollars and twenty-seven
cents in July of 2008 then of course the
price collapsed world economy went into
its tailspin and what we're seeing now
is an oil price like equity markets very
much focused not on the here and now of
how the economy is functioning now but
the expectation of a strong economic
recovery and an oil market that's very
much looking towards China in particular
India and other countries as a source of
growth so this is a an expectations led
rally in the price of oil I see so the
but once the price of oil goes starts
going up wouldn't that then crimp a
growth of that the expect well I think
that is it was you know if we went back
to two thousand eight there were those
who said the price of oil is going to go
up the way it's going up is
going to have a negative effect on the
economy and it delivered a wallop to the
automobile industry to the airline
industry to people of moderate incomes
before before Lehman Brothers collapsed
it created a lot of problems for
countries like India that subsidize
energy prices and and and billions of of
subsidies so I think people forget that
it has those impacts and at some point a
rising oil price does act as a drag on
the world economy we found the last time
I don't think we're at that point now
but higher prices would act as a drag
and you either do something prices
matter or they don't matter and I think
prices matter a lot mm-hmm in the in a
decent report your Center for the Study
of F for the research of energy research
has reported that osed demand for oil
has peaked and it is kind of on the
trending down that could be a good news
for the market because if osed demand is
is declining so the rising demand from
the low energy yeah it acts as as it has
an offset yes and that again it's one of
the things that I point out in this new
edition of the prize when oil prices
were going up demand was weakening and
in fact we passed through a period of
peak demand in the OECD countries in the
United States in Europe Japan will see
some recovery with recovery but we have
their very important trends that work
from more efficient cars biofuels
perhaps electric cars changes in
demographics population is aging which
tell us that we're going to have peak
demand in the established countries so
you have the world on the split in two
when it comes to oil the future of oil
and this is very interesting they're
such if you could give a little more
detail as to how constants demography
how is it affecting the
what demand right well as an example if
we look at it for instance in a
developed country like the United States
an aging population drives less a second
thing that happened to this big source
of demand growth in the United States
was women entering the labor force over
a period about 30 years that's now
saturated so those are you know two
examples on the other hand you look at a
country like China and what you're
looking at is rapidly rising incomes and
rapidly rising incomes or associated
with motorization I think one of the
most extraordinary statistics from the
year 2009 was that many more millions of
more new cars were sold in China than
the United States people knew always
knew that was going to happen but they
thought it would happen in 20 19 or 20
20 not in 2009 and that trend continues
and then you look at a country like
India where the the structure the
demographics it's a much younger nation
and that will have impact on economic
growth in India and of course also again
the appetite for cars so one big
question for the future of world energy
demand is not only will people buy cars
because they will but what kind of cars
hmm whether the scarce would be the gas
guzzler thought it would be more
electric car or more or just more
efficiency what if I wanted the certain
trends one of the other major themes
that I focused on in this new edition of
the prize and continued to work on is we
see an emphasis on energy efficiency
across the world to a degree that we've
really never seen before so it may be
talked about in Europe Japan the United
States but it's also at the top of the
list in China and so yes there'll be
more cars but it makes it real different
whether those cars get 20 miles to the
gallon or 40 miles to the gallon now
this what is driving this push towards
efficiency is it the price or is it
concern about co2 emission I think
what's the change is traditionally the
emphasis in efficiency came from
price concerns about security general
views of the environment and also
particularly in the industrial sector
engineers want to be more efficient
rather than less efficient a little
different when it comes to SUVs I think
there are two new factors that are at
work in it one is the concern about
climate change and the biggest
short-term thing you can do is to be a
lot more efficient and the other is the
sense that with the the bricks with the
success of globalization you're going to
have with these large population
countries if you're not more efficient
the call and resources is just going to
be enormous and so and what is the
concern disk this concern about global
warming as well as energy shortfall is
perhaps the driving the search for
alternative energy and in that area what
what are we seeing what are the
prospects in the next clip well the the
biggest development in renewables the
one that's sort of galloping along is
wind and it's you know you're almost
hard-pressed to say that wind is an
alternative anymore because possible
that forty percent of the new capacity
being out in the United States in the
near term will be wind although their
new competitive factors at work
photovoltaics certainly the cost will
come down a lot getting more widespread
costs have to come down more but if you
say if you're an electric utility and
you have to meet renewable standards and
you have wind supply in your region wind
is the way to do it however if you ask
the question what's the biggest energy
in the innovation since the year 2000
it's not wind not solar if you look at
in volumetric terms it's what's called
unconventional natural gas and so-called
shale gas which has really sort of taken
the us by surprise beginning to take
canter by surprise and is this as now
great interest both in Europe and in
China to see how extensive it is
this is the gas that can be accepted
with some technology that is that but
has not been tapped so far be required
technological innovation do it I mean
the energy industries and you know I
remember when I was first writing the
work in the prize and and people asked
me what's the book about and I realized
when you're writing about energy you're
also right about the history of
innovation because again and again
people think we've now come to the end
there's no where to go and what happens
innovation problems get solved we see it
with with the entrance of silicon valley
venture capital now under this
continuing step up which began in the
bush administration really accelerated
now with Obama to increase spending on
research and development all of that's
going to lead to surprises and certainly
we've never seen the emphasis on
innovation all across the energy
spectrum that we're seeing today mm-hmm
now I've seen some report that this new
technology that is being used to tap gas
could be creating some unintended
consequences in terms of creating a week
straight a' which may not support data
evolve or some geological published
turbulence can be caused is that well I
mean the major issue you hear being
discussed is water and in shale gas as
with all energy developments you have to
manage your water very carefully and
it's a pretty highly regulated activity
as it is I said so you don't see any
sort of bad consequence coming out of
this you know I think the technology
fracking there been a million wells that
have been as I safe wrap these that term
fracked in the United States so it's
it's not a uncanny IC technology I say
okay so-so but apart from this new gas
extraction technology that we have some
report about research about algae how do
you see the prospect of
well we've it's been a subject of you
know I'd say go back five six seven
years people have been working on it
you've seen some major companies now
starting to spend very significant
dollars on it the challenge there is
again if you take the United States
there's a biofuels requirement that by
the year twenty twenty-two at about
twenty percent of us motor fuel should
be biofuels you can't do that with
conventional crops ethanol they're just
limits to it so therefore there's a
great desire to and drive to find a
so-called second or even third
generation of biofuels and that's going
to take that's algie's one of it and
we've seen companies like Exxon Mobil
committee six hundred million dollars
over a ten-year period to work on it
which is significant but i think that
people are working on it say that it is
like all these things it doesn't happen
overnight it really takes development
you can do things in laboratory but the
challenge of energy is that it's big you
need scale and it has to be economically
competitive and that's the role of
research and development and how would
jet Droppa again it gets talked about I
think I it seems to it was a hot more of
a hot subject a few years ago than it
seems to be today and you get all these
things that become hot yeah the big
thing right now of course is what's
going to happen with the electric car
what's going to happen with batteries in
terms of ability to drive long distances
weight efficiency and if you say where
is the biggest emphasis now that's a
very big emphasis when you look at both
what the automobile industry is doing
and what governments are encouraging so
let's say that's probably about how to
subject today that made more efficient
battery right and the ability to charge
it yeah fast charge you need a fast
charge
and you want to bring down the weight I
think those are the two things so the
other costs confirmed that was pretty
high over a year ago about Chinese going
around and acquiring sort of reserves of
oil and many persons of the world and
that the Chinese are coming and we're
going to take over the energy and how do
you see that fear has I think that's
subsided there's no question that the
Chinese are continuing to spend money
and it's like it's almost as other kind
of playing a game of catch up there
looking at their demand now second
largest consumer of oil in the world
they have you know very capable oil
companies they've been in the oil
business for you know for many decades
now so in a way you sort of say it's not
it would almost be expected and given
the world's needs if the Chinese were
consuming so much and not investing in
new supplies that would be a bigger
problem so this is so I think we have to
look at at two levels is the commercial
challenge and if you're a company
competing against the chap to Chinese
you're very aware of that and you're
aware that they may pay a higher price
than you but I think from a sort of it's
important that we keep see these in
commercial terms and not turn it into a
zero-sum kind of mercantilist view and
rather see it as a was part of a larger
web and nexus of economic relations but
and I think you're I would share your
perception that there was a lot more
concerned about this few years ago than
the other other aspect is the refining
capability the Chinese are the world's
second largest consumer or how much of
this actually they define on how much of
their buying from other well I don't
have that number in my head they've been
building some big refineries to meet
their needs again a few years ago there
was a lot
more concerned that the world was short
of refining capacity but for instance
the United States if I can go to that
you know demand the United States has
roughly fallen by about ten percent in
the last couple of years partly because
of the recession and suddenly those
concerns that there aren't enough
refining capacity have turned around now
to the view that there's a surplus of
refining capacity yeah the Indian the de
lance has built a huge refinery in India
yeah i think it's i believe it's the
largest refiner in the world so and it
just came on stream last year right at a
time when the price rises collapsed
right and that's collapse but it's a
it's a very efficient state-of-the-art
modern refinery and it has the capacity
to supply Asia to supply to growth
markets both in India you know and as as
India is it incomes go up in India you
know today probably in the only consume
about a third as much oil as China but
that number will go up now again it
course it's a very interesting question
about what kind of cars will it be in
India and secondly will the
infrastructure be there because the
Chinese have put an enormous investment
into a highway system and even even with
that you can see that I mean one knows
people in beijing who buy cars but leave
it at home because it takes too long to
drive it yes yes a lost two questions
when the Iraq war began that was a lot
of commentary about this is the world is
about while the Americans have gone to
Iraq to get your ex oil now what is how
is the Iraqi oil industry currently
doing well it looks like the companies
who have 21 the biggest position in the
Iraqi oil industry are the Chinese oil
companies so the notion that oil was
never very clear people say about oil
then you'd say well what do you mean
it's about oil oil is a commodity that
you can buy
was it about concessions what's it about
clearly there's this you know whole set
of strategic issues that surround the
Persian Gulf in the role of Persian Gulf
oil in the world economy but if you just
look at the outcome in the current round
when all these big contracts have now
been done in Iraq American companies are
almost at the bottom of the list so
meaning they could not compete well
because the Chinese were willing to give
better deals I the way the Iraqis
constructed it you know they really kind
of look for the low cost and also the
Chinese are prepared to put a lot of
people into Iraq and so in many many of
the these new concessions that have been
done the Chinese partners are very
prominent I said but but as often
happens again people sort of think it's
very interesting I mean the oil business
has a lot of risk in it and so companies
tend to team up and consorcio to work
together so you'll see Chinese companies
in partnership with European companies
or US companies and partnership with
Asian companies and it's a way of
sharing risk because when you go in
you're going to spend billions of
dollars and you want to kind of spread
it out yeah you know what percentage of
war loyal is the plan right on roughly
in terms of production it's probably
about five percent of world oil they
consume a lot of it and so roughly
around probably around three percent is
exported and guess gasps Iran it's very
interesting has enormous supplies of
natural gas they don't really need
nuclear power because they have so much
natural gas but unlike their neighbors
they have not been able to organize
themselves to become an exporter of
natural gas in fact believe they're an
importer of natural gas and has to do
with their own disorganization within
their own energy industry
now this is a question that of course is
beyond energy expertise expertise in
strategy which you have is if the Obama
administration's attempt to impose harsh
sanctions on Iran holds how expect what
do you expect in terms of impact on the
world market less than if there's
conflict I Suzie I think that would be
the first thing I think Iran at the end
of the day needs revenue so will seek to
export if it can will it be able to
invest in its industry will it be able
to benefit from being part of the global
economy if it doesn't want to be part of
a global nuclear regime will you know
that will will be the test but there is
a lot of surplus capacity in the world
and it's clear that other countries
could easily step in and more than make
up for any missing Iranian phone missing
Iranian oil there's a lot of call it a
security cushion in the world market
partly the result of investment in new
capacity and partly a result of the
downturn and consumption because of the
recession and greater efficiency so from
that perspective this may not be a bad
time to put the screws on it up well it
probably it's it's you know if you're
just thinking strategically you'd say
that there's less impact on the world
markets than doing it during a tight
market it would have been a lot more
difficult to do it in 2005 so often in
history you see that crises or problems
arise because people don't understand
other people or their communications
just pass each other by and so where I
think at one of those times and I think
the Iranians certainly have a
strategy or game that they're playing
but I think if there are seem to be
moving towards at least at this moment
towards a tighter sanction regime and
it's a you know kind of to pose for Iran
a series of choices it's interesting you
know to go back to your question about
natural gas Iran has enormous natural
gas reserves it should be a player in it
but it's as so often happens it's not
the question of the resources you have
in the ground but it's the result of the
decisions that governments make a above
ground and this is certainly one of
those times you mentioned globalization
of demand which you have addressed in
your in your epilogue of you the price
can you elaborate to what do you mean by
global energy demand well this really
goes to the fundamental themes of Yale
global because your online journal about
how globalization is changing the world
and and how we make sense of what's
happening and we've seen a subset of
that in terms of energy it's really the
success of globalization it's rising
rapidly rising incomes which are a
product of the kind of globalization
that we have a note with all the other
issues the world economy and opening up
of the world economy and one consequence
of that of rising incomes is reflected
in rising energy demand and in the old
days even as late as the 1990s when we
talked about oil demand we were talking
about the OECD countries we're talking
about the industrial world the China
India were not figuring in that but if
you look at the period between two
thousand and two thousand seven eighty
five percent of the growth of oil demand
was in developing countries and so this
has major consequences in terms of where
the markets are the relations who the
players are we see new players on the
world market and it also has very
interesting not only economic question
but geopolitical questions and so in a
sense in when we talk about
globalization of demand or seen in oil
is really one mirror of these vast
changes in the world that every week
Yale global tries to make sense of
that's a very adjusting a blemish thank
you well done it again thank you so much
thank you for your very illuminating
comments thank you